i wanted to share with you seven
strategies that i hope might be helpful
that
have informed my thinking
and
might be useful to you one of the things
that i realized is that
for so many of us what is lacking what
is profoundly lacking
in our lives
is white space
in a very literal sense for most of us
if you
look at your
calendar
you're probably going to see a sea of
blue
literally white space
time that is unspoken for
is probably pretty scarce
it's not the worst thing in the world
but it has its consequences
a few years ago
i interviewed david allen and
he told me something interesting
he said it doesn't take a huge amount of
time to have brilliant ideas
but what it takes
is space
it's almost like a zen coan if you roll
it around in your head
but it's true right i mean we all know
if you have to come up with some
innovation some new idea it's not oh i
need to set aside 40 hours and bang my
head against the desk that is not how
the brilliant ideas come right
it comes
sometimes in a moment in a flash you're
in the shower you're walking you're
jogging you're doing something
but what enables it to come is having
the space to make the connections
we will never get that space
if we are constantly pulled down
by details by worries by ruminations and
by back-to-back meetings that are so
intense we feel we can never catch up
we need white space if we are going to
have the mental bandwidth to be able to
even begin to engage in long-term
thinking
to be able to step back enough from our
present circumstances to entertain those
questions
number two
if we are ever to truly excel at
something if we're willing to
take what's necessary to be great we
have to be willing to choose what to be
bad at what are we willing to give up
to get there
most of us refuse to choose
and by not choosing
we stay average
that's when i learned that long-term
thinking
is in a lot of ways a test of character
it's a test of the courage
to make choices
i'll give you an example there was a
bank that was actually a very successful
bank
and this bank they did something
interesting unlike almost every other
bank these guys stayed open really late
they were open till 8 o'clock week
nights they were open on weekends
fantastic their customers loved it
obviously
but why doesn't every bank do it you
probably know the answer which is that
it's expensive
but what this bank did
they found a way to pay for it
the way they paid for it
is
they took the savings rate the rate on
savings deposits they shrunk it down
they made it almost non-existent it was
kind of terrible
but to their customers it didn't really
matter
it was a lot more important it was a lot
more salient to be able to go to the
bank at 7 30 at night
but most companies are not willing to
make those hard choices and most people
are not either
number
three we also have to balance our
portfolio
for most of us if you literally know one
thing about personal finance what you
probably know is that it is a bad idea
to put all your eggs in one basket right
you don't want to own one stock
most people think that's a pretty bad
idea you want to balance your portfolio
you want to have some of your money in
cash and some of your money in moonshots
so often
we tend to just
focus in we have our day job okay we're
doing our day job the rest of our time
might be taken up with family or other
responsibilities
i want to urge you to think about
carving out time maybe twenty percent is
too much fine
you can find five percent but to think
about what your speculative long-term
activity is what is your learning edge
where are you
growing something that comes up a lot
when it comes to
long-term thinking and pursuing
long-term projects
is
this question of
when and whether to quit
it can almost feel like you're going
into a dark tunnel
right
because you don't really know
what's going on you don't really know
for sure if it's working
in the midst of developing an
exponential technology there is
something that they dubbed the deception
phase
now what is that
if you're
moving forward with digital photography
and you're able to get it from point
zero one pixels to point zero two pixels
to point zero four pixels
that's actually kind of amazing right
point zero eight when moving on and on
it's actually kind of amazing
progression it's doubling it's doubling
it's doubling but the problem
is that
it's still
invisible to the naked eye
the world around you unless they are
looking very closely they can't tell the
difference and you know
or you hope
you think you know
that you're making progress but it's
often very very
hard to drown out the voices of all the
people around you saying
it's so overblown
that's the deception phase
once we make enough progress to get from
1 to 2 to 4 to 16
all of a sudden people start to say whoa
where did that come from
it's been doubling all along
they just couldn't see it
but for so many of us
if we're working on a project that's
important to us
if we are
building a career
things take time number five
strategic patience
sometimes things do take a while
and that can be exceptionally annoying
i don't like it that they take a while
sometimes but you know what being mad at
the seed does not make the seed grow
faster it takes however long it takes
jeff bezos
was interviewed
and they asked him what is it
that is amazon's competitive advantage
why is amazon so successful
and what he said i think is quite
powerful he said amazon is willing to
invest on a seven year time frame
if it takes seven years for something to
show a profit
it's okay
he said our competitors are only willing
to invest on a three-year time frame
they have to turn a profit within that
time frame if they don't
they're going to scrap it they're not
even going to try it
that is the competitive advantage
if we can be willing
to out weight and outlast the people
around us
if we can be
willing to endure the deception phase
for longer
it enables us to tackle
bigger
harder more meaningful more strategic
problems
number six
fail fast
we know
that failure
in many places around the world is
stigmatized pretty heavily you get one
chance you blow it all right sorry no
more chances
it's also important to recognize
that something is not a failure
until you call it
it's not a failure until you stop trying
the last point that i wanted to make is
that as we think
about our own long-term
future our own long-term vision
in a lot of ways the
north star that we can look to
is a really simple question
what kind of person
do you want to be
this is
a friend of mine her name is alyssa cohn
i write about her alyssa maybe like some
of you guys
was a huge hamilton fan
when she learned that lin-manuel miranda
had a new side project they created
an academy it was a training program to
teach regular people how to do freestyle
hip hop rap
just like the performers
she immediately said i'm in that sounds
great
she shows up for class
and when she shows up she realizes it's
alyssa
and about 20
guys who are all about two decades
younger than her and who are all
extremely good rappers
after the first class she emailed the
instructor and she said i'm really sorry
to do this i feel like i should withdraw
i i it's just you know i don't fit in i
don't i don't think i can do this
and he wrote back to her
with some incredibly wise words
he said alyssa
the goal
is not to turn you
into a professional rapper
the goal
is to help you become a more creative
and uninhibited person
and she thought about it and she
realized
oh right
that is my goal
she spent two months
every monday night taking the hip hop
improv beatbox rap classes
and just before
the world shut down in 2020 she gave a
concert performance with her class and
she had friends from all over see her
perform improv rap but ultimately the
question that i think all of us can ask
ourselves
as we think long term as we think about
our vision for our own lives and how we
want to lead them
is what kind of person do you want to be
what are you
optimizing for
[Music]
you